mein name ist sieht es bereits intel
eingeblendet wir machen heute eine
versuchen nicht zu weinen challenger mir
eine hundeschule und zwar die
southeastern guide dogs also hier werden
anscheinend blindenhunde ausgebildet
hier ist ein kleiner welpe das
wahrscheinlich sein erster tag an der
schule und 9
[Musik]
wo man nicht weiß schon worauf das
hinausläuft er wird ja wahrscheinlich
gar keine freunde finden oder irgendwie
so aber er freut sich dennoch weil es
ist sein erster tag an der canyon
university
er geht jetzt die reha zentren zu hause
jeder blindenhund wird nicht von
menschen ausgebildet sondern hier an der
southeastern guide dogs geliehen
university aber wir schauen wir weiter
er läuft auf jeden fall jetzt hier in
die schule rein sieht die ganzen preise
von irgendwelchen anderen guide dogs er
will wahrscheinlich aus und krasser hund
werden nun 1 1
so groß sein okay er wird er wird
reingelassen okay das ist jetzt
eigentlich schon was relativ cool ist
hipp heißt der hund wahrscheinlich hier
werden nun sachen beigebracht die hunde
melden sich und online das gesehen der
kanal kann da gar nicht drüber gucken
jetzt gehts hier eine praxis und die
dame ist blind und der hohen schaft gar
nichts er bekommt was zu essen und er
[Applaus]
mit pippi jetzt schon voll da ist
[Musik]
und ja das ganze online und stopper
wieder hin
der mann ist so richtig so hey ich will
doch nur das beste und sie faktisch alle
total ab jetzt schaut er sich die ganzen
preise wieder an von irgendwelchen
anderen guide dogs jetzt besser denn je
also dass das ist wirklich eine gute
idee mein lieber pip mal schauen wie es
jetzt weitergeht mit der dame er geht
einfach
[Musik]
das verstehe ich nicht wieso er ist
jetzt einfach stehen geblieben wie so
konnte das denn vorher nicht machen
jetzt ist auf jeden fall gerade pausen
leute nach es extra day okay jetzt wird
hier der finale abschluss test ob sie es
geschafft haben
tipp läuft vor der typ sieht böse aus
[Musik]
nein das heißt auch dass es
wahrscheinlich weggeschickt wird ja wird
rausgeschickt hohmann der arme und das
ist dieser ace ist dieser hund
wahrscheinlich von den ganzen preisen
und die anderen haben es alle geschafft
nein nein nein nein hätte sie sorry aber
was bringt so was wenn der typ der
einfach drunter herbstritt alt für hilfe
erhält die frau und an der handtasche
sieht er sie über den abgrund
und rettet sie wort- und klein und die
anderen jungs gesehen
und nein jetzt bekommt er das von diesem
alter da kann man wirklich mal klatschen
das ist neu es ist aber so dass so
müssen zufälle einfach kommen also das
war wirklich eine sehr sehr sehr sehr
schöne animation
ich war wirklich den tränen nah also es
war also noch richtige glücksgefühle
keine ahnung hätte wirklich gänsehaut
dann als er die gerettet hat und so das
war wirklich daran
aber ich habe noch eine weitere
animation vorbereitet hier ist ein
kleines mädchen im jahr 1996 in russland
da bin ich tatsächlich geworden ich weiß
nicht was ein waisenhaus ist hier sind
ganz viele betten aber nur das von ihr
nur das licht dann nur dass es belegt
sie steht jetzt die hat man die scheibe
geschrieben sind immer noch keine
anderen kinder da sie liegt er immer
noch alleine im waisenhaus
sie hatten sie hat irgendwas geschenkt
bekommen auch so ein kleines tierchen
wahrscheinlich das erste was hat sie
gesagt ich kann kein russisch die musik
wird ein bisschen schneller das heißt
jetzt wird sie wahrscheinlich irgendwie
aus wie klein sie ist das hier ist ein
halber türrahmen und 30 zentimeter hoch
oder sowie hat jetzt hier andere freunde
gefunden bzw
vielleicht andere waisenkinder hier
irgendwie
[Musik]
warum lachen jetzt plötzlich los jetzt
streichen sie sogar das komplette
waisenhaus da irgendwie an sie sind
jetzt alle auch schon ein bisschen
erwachsener geworden also alle jetzt
schon irgendwie junge erwachsene hier
und wer hoch
der zug an hier sie fördern
nach hause und hat sogar eine eigene
tochter am ende war eine schöne
animationen aber geweint habe ich jetzt
auch nicht nun schauen wir uns
allerdings noch eine weitere tier
animation an wir haben hier wale unter
wasser die hier durchs meer schwimmen
etwas gesagt
seit wann können wale singen
auch das lied
hier haben wir sieben kleine süße und
jetzt auch und jetzt kommen die menschen
und jagen wahrscheinlich auch ein und
machen die natur kaputt und die wilderer
das ist nicht eine animation die sonst
wo man wein sondern wo man einfach
nachdenkt willst du was ich meine ganzen
ölplattform
[Musik]
und das öl kommt immer näher
die wilde herfahren darum nein
und das ist das online das ist die mama
und das kleinere
si
[Musik]
ihr schicksal
das war bisher die krasseste don't dream
works inc
also die animation war wirklich geil war
mir allerdings nur zum letzten
animationen die uns heute anschauen
werden und zwar eine animation von einem
eisbären und seinem baby also der kleine
eisbär sagt mama du weißt du kein
gewissen geraten können was passiert ist
ich bin aufgewacht und war es nicht da
er schaut raus aus seinem bau aus seiner
höhle
schaut überall nach der mutter findet
sie aber nirgendwo sucht weiter ist ganz
allein der kleine schaut sich immer
weiter um nach der mutter läuft weiter
durch kommentar marktes wieder menschen
denken ein
[Musik]
man weiß doch schon noch was es
hinausläuft okay okay er meint der
schnee hat ihm einen tipp gegeben weil
die fußstapfen noch drin man von der
mutter und ersetzt den fußstapfen weiter
gefolgt werde jetzt hier auf seiner
kleinen eisscholle weiter in richtung
von diesem typen um der kleine eisbär
denken was das denn für ein
[Musik]
der versuch ihn abzuschießen laufwerk
kleiner eisbär sein schließlich habe
ok
[Musik]
ok zumindest der menschen schon mal
gestorben nun geht der kleine eisbär
weitergeführt rum und verfolgt die
spuren von dem fahrzeug und geht jetzt
in das haus rein schaut sich um und
entdeckt
[Musik]
ich finde es unfassbar krass wie
animation oder allgemein filme mit den
gefühlen von uns menschen spielen also
das ist wirklich unfassbar ich habe
keine animation jetzt so richtig geweint
das so wirklich tränen aus meinen augen
kamen aber bei der mit den wilderern und
auch bei der jetzt gerade weil ich
wirklich enorm kurz davor ganz viele von
euch haben wir geschrieben halo carlos
schon so viele nicht lachen challenges
gemacht damals ja wie das hat über
irgendwie 34 millionen aufrufe dagegen
jude da noch alleine wo ich auf 1
reagiert habe habe ich habe noch nie
eine trader challenge gemacht und ich
habe sie gemeistert aber ich war
wirklich echt kurz davor zu heulen ihr
findet selbstverständlich alle
animationen unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt also falls ihr
euch eventuell noch mal ein video
anschauen wollt dann checkt gerne die
video beschreibung ab wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat und ihr euch
eventuell denkt hey luca du könntest
dass der eventuell noch mal machen dann
hast einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
hier da weil diese trailer channel
schalter die hat mir echt zu schaffen
gemacht gerade weil ansonsten abonniert
gern meinen kanal von abonnenten dann
klicken auf die glocke dann bekommt der
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]